detailed demand just for other coins i
mean in addition to dogecoin you also
have things like
ether you have binance coins so there's
this growing comfort
and this growing interest in investing
outside of bitcoin
which for so long was just really much
the the only game in town when it came
to crypto
and if you are looking for a silver
lining though data track it's a research
shop
it looked at historical trends and it
thinks should bitcoin's market share
drop below 40 percent you could see a
rebound in bitcoin
sort of as this by the dip mentality
emerges so
this is going to be something to watch
whether this this altcoin
rally if you want to call it that
continues or at a certain point whether
people looking for a bargain go back
into bitcoin bailey i know you cover
uh meme stocks equities uh closely
i i'm wondering what the relationship is
between the way that people are talking
about doge
in the forums the way that they talked
about it over the weekend what we saw
from elon musk
if if that has any relationship to the
way that they
talked about and and bought into uh
companies like gamestop
i think there's a similarity um the
tougher part is kind of the divide so
people who have adopted doge to katie's
point there are other
companies or other coins to buy into and
we're seeing a lot of money being pushed
into that not necessarily
selling doge but other opportunities
that kind of are catching an interest
it's kind of like looking at
a dog when they see a squirrel they get
excited and they want to chase the next
squirrel that's really what we're seeing
with
some of these cryptocurrencies and it is
similar to gamestop but
we saw gamestop rally take a dip and a
bit of a breather it
hit above 480 twice so there's still
enough
buying demand it's just a question of
will doge be where people want to
continue to put money in
especially with the understanding that
the risk is realistically a hundred
percent there's not really a
sound fundamental basis in doge as
opposed to gamestop where
you can say ryan cohen and they're
selling goods and they're still a
company
dogecoin could drop to zero
theoretically tomorrow and there's no
reason that it should go any other
direction so bailey then
i guess should we even be thinking about
whether this is peak doge or not i mean
is it just going to continue to change
every day
i think it is it's something we've seen
in the past when elon musk was announced
that he was going to be headlining or
guest hosting snl we saw that the crypto
run
drop and we've seen a number of 50 ish
dips and then as katie said people buy
those dips we don't really know again
it's
it's tough to try to talk about or look
into the future of something that
up to this point hasn't made much sense
uh so we could have been peak dosh we
could see
people buying into ether or other
kryptos or kind of just go back about
their their days and go
live life and enjoy going to bars and
concerts and restaurants and neither
would be surprising but
as long as you have a movement uh it
really will be tough to die and elon
obviously is doing everything in his
power
to keep doge relevant and to keep doge
in the headlines hey
katie to bailey's point about ether and
people buying into ether
uh let's talk a little bit about the
idea of froth which some analysts
have brought up with broth in the in the
crypto market for example jp morgan says
it's retail trader demand for
uh other coins is potentially uh
whittling away bitcoin market share uh
potentially
froth that is is reminiscent of what
happened in 2017 where we saw a big
sell-off
in bitcoin uh take me through
similarities to what analysts are saying
now
uh versus what happened back then and
and what it means for the legitimacy of
crypto
well froth feels like the favorite word
on wall street right now and it's
definitely been thrown around a lot when
it comes to cryptocurrencies
and it goes back again to that market
share argument that you're seeing
bitcoin's market share just
whittled away by all of this interest in
altcoins
some of them serious such as ether some
of them you know
a joke such as dogecoin but i really
want to dial in on ether because i think
this is really interesting because
in the realm of serious cryptocurrencies
ether definitely falls into that
bucket because it's the currency the
cryptocurrency used within the ethereum
blockchain which is
powering things such as non-fungible
tokens which are very hot right now
and jp morgan's warning that this feels
like 2017 in terms of
just how much froth there is in the
crypto market right now they also
applied that to ether specifically
saying that
even though the ethereum blockchain
network it has a lot of promise
the ether rally that we're seeing it hit
4 000
today even though we were talking about
3 000 last week
the the rally there it's starting to
outpace the actual activity that you're
seeing on the ethereum network so
they actually estimate that ether's fair
value is probably closer to
1 000 and again we're at 4 000 so
that's a pretty big disconnect so
whether this froth boils over and we see
this
bubble pop if you want to call it that
remains to be
seen but you i think that they're trying
to make the point that you would
probably see it in this
this altcoin sphere that is really just
on fire right now
well to explain explain exactly what
analysts mean when they say froth the
term that we heard from
fed chair uh jay powell just a few weeks
ago when he gave his press conference
but essentially what they're saying is
hey
there are signs that things are a little
overvalued exactly that that just
there's a lot of exuberance and
excitement in the market right now
not just in crypto you could easily
apply that argument to the stock market
as well
and that things have gotten a little bit
ahead of themselves and
again in ether's case there's a lot of
promise in the ethereum blockchain
they're not discounting that
but just the magnitude of this rally and
the pace of these gains
it's starting to get a little bit ahead
of itself and you could see that asset
correct
hey bailey what are you looking at next
i mean what should we be paying
attention to now that snl has passed us
i mean
uh elon musk is still talking about
dogecoin but um
what are you going to be paying
attention to i'm still paying attention
to
some of the uh over-the-counter traded
stocks some of these smaller more
speculative uh
meme stocks a lot of retail traders are
still have the
get rich buy lotto tickets uh mentality
when they're making these investments
obviously they are putting money into
you know your big blue chip uh
tech companies you're they're putting
money into amazon's the microsoft's of
the world
but there still is a mentality that if i
can turn a thousand dollars into thirty
thousand dollars and buy a car
i'm gonna take that risk and so a lot of
people are still looking at
um those opportunities be it gamestop
still is a bit overrun but looking at
you know naked brands or express are
still companies that are thinly traded
have the opportunity to see big
booms and busts if they can just get the
right chat room to pick up the right
chatter and then see everyone else jump
into it so it's a lot of trying to play
ahead of the curve
or to use a hockey terms to skate to
where the puck's going to go
and try to beat the crowd and that's
something we saw initially with doge
um just a couple months ago bloomberg
katie grieffeld and bailey lip schultz
love talking crypto thank you for
joining us on quick take this morning
great to see both of you
well coming up why the shutdown of
another nuclear power plant in new york
could be a setback for u.s
emissions goals we're back in two
minutes to explain this is quick take
charge
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenovich and i'm jennifer zappasaja
in new york
in new york's indian in new york indian
point's last nuclear reactor went dark
in april
it's the 12th nuclear reactor to close
since 2013
and will be replaced by fossil fuels for
the short term that
may hurt the us's ambitions in green
energy production so quick takes ryan
cavatero visited the plant
a week before it went dark take a listen
nuclear is in a crisis mode nuclear
power
provides the greatest amount of
carbon-free generation that the u.s has
today
35 miles north of manhattan two nuclear
reactors provided around 25 percent of
the electricity for the big
apple you do the math you understand why
indian
points closure is absolutely the only
smart move
but losing a nuclear reactor hurts the
us's goals of a carbon-free future
this is a decade we must make decisions
that will avoid the worst consequences
of the climate crisis
this is the story of indian point energy
center and how the closed power plant
can
impede zero emissions goals and be a
specter of a vanishing
atomic future well it used to be that
indian point
was an amusement park which is kind of
amazing to me families took boats up the
hudson river to buchanan new york to
ride the roller coasters
there's 300 miles of the hudson river
it's been a conduit for commerce haven
for recreation
nuclear reactors require a lot of water
to keep them cool they must have looked
at that property and thought oh this is
a great place
for a nuclear plant
con edison acquired the land in 1954.
the company finished construction of the
unit 1 nuclear reactor
in 1964. two more reactors followed
unit 2 went online in 1974 and unit 3 in
1976
and then in 2000 entergy purchased unit
3 from the state
and unit 2 from con ed when both of
those reactors were operating it
supplied about 25 percent of the
electricity to
new york city it's a very valuable piece
of power
before we continue about indian point
what is nuclear power
fission nuclear power is splitting of
heavy elements like uranium
into smaller particles and in the
process of doing that releasing a
tremendous amount of energy that energy
in the form of heat
is used to heat water that is then
turned into steam
and that steam goes ahead and spins the
turbine and generates electricity
nuclear is complex technology obviously
this is michael schellenberger he's an
author and he's advocated for nuclear
power
in front of congress but the plants
themselves are just power plants there's
steam generators that spin turbines that
make electricity
over the years attitudes started to
shift towards indian point
there's two reasons the combinations a
lot of political opposition
from environmental groups to go ahead
and close the nuclear power plant
because they were scared
especially in the wake of fukushima that
a similar accident could happen
over here river keeper has been watching
the
indian point power plant for decades
we've observed
that as the plant ages it becomes more
of a safety risk beyond its failure to
comply with the clean water act
the indian point plant consumes more
water every day than the city of new
york
and after 9 11 we realized that as this
plant ages
it becomes more and more of a risk to
the 20 million people who live within 50
miles
entergy disputes those claims pointing
to large investments in plant safety
and reliability there are people on all
sides of this issue there were people
that
never wanted the plant here and other
people recognized the value to the
economy
then in 2017 amid contract discussions
new york governor andrew cuomo and
entergy made a decision
i've personally been trying to close it
down for 15 years
finally this year i'm proud to announce
that we have an agreement
indian point will close in four years 14
years
ahead of schedule
in addition to environmental concerns
the economics in an unregulated power
market
no longer made sense in january 2017
entergy announced that it was shutting
down indian point unit 2 by
2020 unit 3 by 2021 the primary decision
was related to
a drop in wholesale power prices i mean
the big story in energy of course over
the last decade and a half
is the fracking revolution which made
natural gas really cheap in the united
states and that's put price pressure on
both coal plants and nuclear plants in
some places
the decommissioning process will take
around 15 years
new yorkers will be safer from the risk
of a disaster at the plant but
what will replace the lost energy
between 2017 and 2021
when they were planning on
decommissioning the reactors almost
two gigawatts of fossil fired power came
online within 50 miles of
indian point so unfortunately we are
replacing
in the immediate future the electricity
generated by indian point
not by renewables but by fossil fuels in
the form of those
natural gas power plants an indian point
i think stands
as a dramatic warning that carbon
emissions will go up
we have very very ambitious goals
present administration has also
said that it wants to have a carbon-free
electrical power system
by 2035. it's not possible to
radically reduce your carbon emissions
or your use of fossil fuels without
nuclear power the nuclear right now
provides a little bit under 20 percent
of our electricity
i think the biden climate legislation
gives so much subsidies to solar and
wind that it could end up accelerating
the closure of nuclear plants
and thus have a counterproductive impact
in terms of emissions
you know when the sun sets is when
people come home from work and start to
use all their power so there's no
innovation to solar panels that can make
them
work better at night and wind similarly
is not reliable
especially if you think that weather is
becoming more extreme
nuclear power plants they're very very
dense source electricity that generates
a lot of electricity
all the time the power sources of the
future will be a combination of
renewables
and nuclear power if we are really
serious about
reaching net zero in the time frames
that the current administration has gone
ahead and identified
indian point unit 3 is the 12th reactor
to close since the beginning of 2013.
right now there are 55 sites and 93
reactors in operation
reactors in michigan and california are
expected to close in the next few years
and there are two advanced reactor sites
under construction in georgia
that have exceeded original budgets
i mean the most important thing for the
united states to do right now is to
keep our nuclear power plants operating
and build more reactors
similar to the ones that are already in
construction in georgia
nuclear is both scary and beneficial for
the same reason i think a lot of people
have viewed
the ability to do that as a curse or
that we'll be in trouble with the gods
but i think that increasingly people
understand it as a blessing nuclear
power plants
cannot go off like a weapon and they
don't depend on weapons or vice versa
but it's sort of the anxieties from one
have displaced onto the other and that's
why you get people that believe things
that just aren't true
so how does nuclear power fit into our
energy
future there's a lot of policy
mechanisms that policymakers at the
state or the federal level can use
but i think really what matters is being
able to explain to people why nuclear is
an
important technology that's here to stay
it's not something that we
could or should try to get rid of and
said we need to make the most of it
and thanks to quick takes ryan cavatero
for that really great reporting
coming up does a 40 000 one-time bonus
sound good to you i think it would
well some companies are doubling their
bonuses to try to keep
employees from jumping ship we'll
explain in two minutes with the details
this is quick take charge
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenovich and i'm jennifer zabasaja
in new york so let's look at some
developing stories we are tracking this
morning
president biden is preparing for his
first face-to-face meeting with
republican leaders mitch mcconnell
and kevin mccarthy wednesday's meeting
comes as republicans
are ramping up their opposition to the
president's 4 trillion dollar economic
plan there's not much expectation for a
breakthrough
at the meeting there's not much there's
not much
expectation for a breakthrough at the
meeting last week mcconnell said he is a
hundred percent focused
on blocking biden's agenda
and you can learn more about these
stories and stay up to date with the
day's news at bloomberg.com well that's
going to do it for quick take this hour
but there's much more quick tip coming
up in just a minute i'm tim stenovich
i'm jennifer zaba
to check out these stories at
bloomberg.com or our quick take on
social media
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
quick tip where we bring you today's top
news and break down how it intersects
with the world of business coming up
this weekend exposed another
vulnerability to america's
infrastructure the hack against the
colonial pipeline
comes as more people are hitting the
road for the pandemic comeback this
summer
we're talking about the impact this will
have on your gas prices
what it means for biden's infrastructure
plan and what we know about the group
allegedly behind the attack
then we're seeing another sign of
inflation in grocery stores around the
world
food prices are jumping this year with
just about everything costing more than
it did a year ago
so why did seafood prices go up 18
and how are people changing their buying
habits and it was an interesting
saturday for dogecoin elon musk's
appearance on snl led to a massive
sell-off but volatility is the name of
the game for these altcoins and
bitcoin's market share has dropped in
recent months
prompting more questions about whether
that segment of the cryptocurrency
sector
is ripe for a reckoning good morning
everyone it's monday may 10th
i'm tim stenovich and i'm jennifer
zabastaja this is quick take charge
let's get going
[Music]
good morning everyone thanks so much for
joining us this morning crude oil and
gasoline rose after a cyber attack put
the largest oil products pipeline in the
u.s
out of action colonial pipeline says
it's still developing a plan for
restarting and will
only do so when it's safe there's little
clarity
over when it'll be back up and running
there are increasing concerns over the
possibility of shortages of gasoline and
diesel across the eastern u.s
joining us now is bloomberg opinions
liam denning liam thanks so much for
joining us this morning what does this
hack this ransomware situation
say about america's energy security
uh well it's it's not good um
you know i think one of the most
troubling aspects of this and
it's very hard to have any detail about
it right now but
you know broadly speaking these systems
tend to have
um sort of high level computer systems
used by the people in the offices you
know things like email that sort of
thing that we all use and then there are
operational systems that actually run
the pipeline and and
they're generally kept separate what's
troubling about this is that
um whoever did this really does seem to
have knocked out
um you know one of the most critical
pieces of uh oil infrastructure in
in the country and in fact on the planet
hey liam
can you just talk about a little bit um
about what we know about the people
the gang that may be behind it this dark
side what have you learned in the past
few days
well we don't actually know a lot about
them you know they were linked to the
to the solar winds hack and you know one
of the things that emerged over the
weekend
was that like that incident um it seems
like they did
actually manage to steal quite a bit of
data
before the pipeline itself was was shut
down
it is apparently a ransomware attack
one thing to keep in mind is that
you know it's very important to
determine with these kind of things
whether it's a
a private criminal group or a state
actor but
the problem is the way these things work
it's very hard to really disentangle
those things because
you know state actors can can hire
these shadowy groups that lurk out there
you know on the dark web
and um it's very unclear really who's um
who's ultimately
um pulling the strings on this kind of
attack well let's bring in cyber
security reporter william turton who
joins us on the phone now uh william
good morning
what is the latest with the hack itself
what do we know about
the the people behind it and and the
possibility of this pipeline getting
back
uh on in the coming days hi thanks for
having me
so we know darkseid is kind of this
criminal organization that has
used ransomware on other organizations
this is of course their kind of biggest
attack yet
this morning there is a statement
released on their website an almost kind
of comical statement that says
you know we're not involved in
geopolitics do not try to tie us to any
government
our goal is just to make money and
quote not create problems for our
society so we really don't know how bad
it is
at colonial um and and you know even if
it is sort of a best case scenario if
you will let's just say for example they
pay the ransom
it still might take a long time for this
to come back online because recovering
from one of these attacks can be really
timely
hey william just on that note in terms
of paying for
um what this potential these hackers
have
are asking for is that the typical
response
when this sort of thing happens i mean
we mentioned solarwinds a few minutes
ago
um would that potentially resolve what's
happening i mean how does this usually
get resolved
sure so remember solarwinds was more
espionage it wasn't a ransomware
campaign it was just a kind of steel
information um but you know so
the official line from the fbi for
example is not to pay
because you know you're essentially
funding these criminals but it really
varies in a lot of scenarios
um and you know sometimes your only
option is to pay if you don't have
backups
it really depends on a case-by-case
scenario
and whether you're willing to you know
pay someone that's holding you hostage
like this
um and how important it is you know in a
scenario like this to get critical
infrastructure back online
liam speaking of that critical
infrastructure you raised the idea
of president biden's infrastructure plan
and the way that this changes
potentially the narrative
around selling it to democrats and
republicans
um what would you like to see in terms
of infrastructure spending
to keep this type of infrastructure safe
well you would think that um you know
spending money
to to strengthen infrastructure you know
and there's obviously a lot of
disagreement about what constitutes
infrastructure right now but spending
money
to keep it safe from this kind of attack
would seem like a no-brainer
um part of the problem here is obviously
the the um the atmosphere in washington
uh and the interplay of gasoline prices
would make me think that we actually may
just see more conflict
around this you know one thing about
biden's climate policy
is one of the things that's emboldened
him is that americans aren't paying much
for energy
right now partly because you know oil
prices crashed because of covid and
we've been driving less
et cetera et cetera um if you see
gasoline prices spike
because of this kind of incident you
know it gives biden's opponents
something to latch onto in order to
attack his entire
approach on infrastructure and climate
hey liam today we're talking about
colonial pipeline uh which
roughly can uh the east coast makes up
roughly 50
45 percent of fuel consumed on the east
coast which is really significant
if you think about it but what else
could potentially be
a target for hackers who are now looking
at this situation
and others that have happened in recent
months what do you think
could potentially be next um
well you know i mean we can speculate
about all sorts of things you know
clearly our energy systems depend on
these
these um these very large very
interconnected
networks which which creates all sorts
of points of vulnerability you know the
electricity grid is an obvious
candidate um when i was talking earlier
about whether a state actor
uh may have been behind this i mean that
that is kind of a doomsday scenario
because
it's sort of common knowledge that most
of the major powers
you know have this ability to mess with
each other's critical
energy infrastructure generally they shy
away from doing it because it's
it represents a major escalation and i
think
if this does get traced back eventually
to any kind of state actor
the u.s response would be would be
pretty aggressive
william i got to tell you i mean just
from a layperson's standpoint it seems
like
the u.s is is is really vulnerable here
and it seems like we've
looked just the number of articles that
you've written about attacks
uh just in the past six months and the
way that
ransomware seems to be more common than
not
when it comes to fishing and when it
comes to the way that
that state actors or non-state actors as
bad actors are targeting it just seems
like
we are just not prepared for what's out
there right now
yeah i mean it's safe to say at a
minimum ransomware is spiraling out of
control and not only just ransomware
right like
you know of them locking up your
computers and demanding money for it we
reported that
this hacking group sold almost 100
gigabytes of data
from colonial pipeline and is
threatening to release that data as well
if they don't pay the ransom so it's
kind of a double extortion scenario
which is
frankly it's becoming the norm with
ransomware
um and you know this attack is is one of
the most bold and brazen yet in the us
but also remember
you know right before the election and
then during a peak in coba the
ransomware groups were really
aggressively targeting hospitals
so there's really no bottom for these
groups and
it really just keeps getting worse and
it doesn't seem like there's any
remediation in sight will you do we know
anything about what this white house
task force is going to be tasked with
doing sort of next on that note that you
just mentioned because it's getting
worse and worse as it seems well i think
mostly they're going to try and mitigate
the damage um
and that's because it might it might
take colonial a long time to get back
online
um you know it's it's really hard to
know right now but
from some folks i've spoken to they've
expressed kind of
frustration or surprise that colonials
didn't have a contingency plan for this
but there's also the scenario you know
what we don't know just you know maybe
the hack is
you know somehow worse or more complex
or different than we realize
um but but i think that that will be the
primary focus of that group and you saw
last night
uh some some restrictions on how long
truck drivers are allowed to drive where
we're eased and you know i imagine
there's going to be more coming
well we're really grateful to have both
of you guys on this top story this
morning bloomberg news is
william turton and bloomberg opinions
liam denning thank you so much for your
time and for joining us
this morning now we don't want to bury
the lead on the rest of the morning's
top news so here are some stories we
don't want you to miss
a horrific bombing at a girls school in
the afghan capital of kabul killed at
least
85 people on saturday many of the
victims were students between the ages
of 11
and 15 years old three explosions
outside the school entrance struck as
students were leaving
for the day in the same neighborhood in
2018 a school bombing killed
34 people the taliban denied
responsibility
condemning the attack and the many
deaths
also in jerusalem weeks of violence
threatened to escalate on the day israel
celebrates its control over the
contested
city palestinians clashed with israeli
police and at least 50 palestinians were
hospitalized
israel is marking the anniversary of the
day in 1967
it captured jerusalem's eastern sector
from jordan
and finally prime minister boris johnson
confirmed that the next stage of
lockdown easing in england
will go ahead on may 17th as planned
people will be allowed to stay
overnight with friends or relatives and
indoor hospitality will be reopened last
week
the government said limited
international travel will also resume
10. and you can learn more about these
stories and stay up to date on the day's
news at bloomberg.com
well coming up next a new study says the
u.s actually has more than 300
000 more coveted deaths than have been
reported by the cdc it's something
that didn't necessarily shock dr anthony
fauci we're talking to a doctor from
johns hopkins
university to understand what this means
for the country we're back in two
minutes this
is quick take charge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenoveck and i'm jennifer zabasanja
in new york it's time now for quick take
by the numbers where we give you the
numbers that tell
the story this morning's number is 905
2289. a new study from the university of
washington's
institute for health metrics and
evaluation says that through may the
total number of people in the u.s who
died from coven 19
is actually 905 289 that's significantly
higher
than the 578 520 deaths
reported by the cdc the university of
washington analysis uses excess
mortality data for its figure
on sunday dr anthony fauci director of
the national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases said there's quote
no doubt the u.s has undercounted its
number of deaths from covet 19
but he did also say that the university
of washington analysis is quote
a bit more than i would have thought
well joining us now from baltimore to
discuss is emergency physician at the
johns hopkins university dr gabe callan
dr kellen it's great to have you back on
the show thanks for being here
i'm wondering what your reaction was
when you heard that the death toll
could actually be more than 300 000 more
than we thought that's at least
according to this university of
washington analysis that came out last
week
yeah you know this is uh very
challenging to get at an exact number
but a 50 or so increase
is probably well within the ballpark a
bit higher could be a bit lower
and remember the way this methodology
was done
they looked at the number of deaths
naturally experienced in any given year
and then looked at this last past year
that time that covet has
really taken hold and found that oh
we have 300 000 or so more deaths
than otherwise predicted so it must be
due to
covet now let's also recall that it's
not
all a hundred percent you got infected
with covet and died
these include people who have overdosed
and died which has increased
um became very despondent
and committed suicide and particularly
early on there were
many many patients not counted who
delayed care and were found dead at home
by ems
were never tested and were almost
certainly either delayed care for heart
attacks
strokes and whatnot or stayed at home
very very sick
being afraid to come to the hospital
the number may actually be a tad higher
because in the model
the investigators
discounted properly
lower deaths in certain things like
trauma car accidents and so forth
so related to covet may actually be a
little bit higher
but um yeah that that's probably a
pretty rational number
and we know globally it's probably uh
even way more underestimated given the
way many countries are unable to
accurately count
yeah dr kellen we wanted to ask you
about that i mean what does this
potentially say about
tracking in other countries around the
world
it doesn't say anything about tracking
we know that many countries
do not have the type of resources as
western countries and particularly the
us
which has enormous resources to track
almost each and every
infection that comes to light and then
has a vast army
of academics and scientists who can
model out
components like this as to what we're
not counting
that doesn't exist in many many
countries around the world
i want to talk a little bit about people
who have been
infected uh even after getting the
vaccine it is a
tiny tiny tiny number
of people at the end of april more than
000 americans were reported to be
infected after being vaccinated a tiny
percentage of the 95
million people uh who were fully
inoculated at the time i got to tell you
anecdotally speaking i had someone on
friday
who hasn't gotten the vaccine yet in
this hesitant say to me
i've heard you can still get covet even
after getting the vaccine
and i'm wondering about messaging here
yeah you know messaging is very
difficult because
people who are hesitant
facts don't tend to work so when you say
9 000 people or so have had
uh a new infection that's come to light
out of 95 million um
that is so tiny but the 9000 is what
sticks in
people's minds not the point zero zero
zero one percent
which is also a number that doesn't seem
to you know resonate
with people um you know the the issue is
that
it's tiny and it's not like you can't
get sick enough to go to the hospital
but that number is even
smaller and so yes some people will get
infected
no vaccine is 100 but that 9
000 versus 95 million or so is
tinier than almost any other vaccine
that
is for general public use for an
infectious disease
it's amazingly useful
and it's amazingly protective if that's
what we're really dealing with
so dr kellen then how how should the u.s
continue to encourage people to get
vaccinated of course the president has a
goal
of 70 by july 4th um but there is still
that hesitancy for certain different
reasons from from
different people um what would you say
needs to happen
from the top yeah i think we need to
shift gears and perhaps
uh we already have you know first the
good news right people over
age 65 uh some we're approaching 85
of the us population over 65 have had at
least one shot
and more than 70 have been fully
vaccinated
i mean that's well within the range of
herd immunity for
for that group and for adults it's like
close to 60
at least one shot uh i mean that that's
a that's a big success but as you elude
we are now
running into almost a surplus of vaccine
versus uh those who want it so we know
what doesn't work
right simply spewing facts into people's
faces
showing pictures of people gasping for
air and
calling people stupid and shaming them i
mean those
those types of things don't work we have
learned a couple of things that work
instead of just viewing facts of people
whether you agree with them or not
showing true empathy
to their concerns you have to be able to
connect
the messaging has to come from people
other than
me people that they trust trusted
figures in their communities or churches
or in some cases it's sports figures
uh personal physicians can be very very
powerful here they may not trust almost
anyone other than that long relationship
if people are fortunate enough
to have it and then we've discovered
some interesting techniques
when you bring vaccine instead of making
people come to your clinic for a
vaccination
you do a mobile clinic and come to say
certain
parts of town you set up shop somewhere
and then people start to get vaccinated
others see
that people like them are getting
vaccinated and all of a sudden
they want in and so
there are other types of things that
people have uh this is anecdotal but
um we know a person who like swore up
and down they're never getting the
vaccine they don't believe in it
and then they wanted to go on a cruise
and the crews insisted they get a
vaccine
right so well i guess i i guess i'm
going to get one well
so there are inducements um
[Music]
to really empathize and try and connect
the second is make it easy literally
bring the vaccine to people
and if you need to it's unfortunate but
sometimes inducement works
well dr kellen governor of new jersey
phil murphy said he's been
he's open to the idea of actually paying
people to get
vaccinated what do you make of that yeah
i don't know if i'm the right one
to answer that i'm you know i'm somewhat
uneasy about it but we do have a public
health emergency
so there's kind of pros and cons once
you start paying people to do the right
thing
then you're gonna have to start paying
forever
every time you want a major campaign
like this that is
uh in behalf of the public health on the
other hand we have a deadly disease
still amongst us
and we want to stamp this out as fast as
possible
emergency physician at johns hopkins
university dr gabe callan
live from baltimore dr kellen thanks so
much for for taking the time and for
joining us this morning
we should note that the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health is
supported by michael r bloomberg founder
of bloomberg lp
in bloomberg philanthropies well coming
up we are talking inflation specifically
food inflation our grocery bills are
going up quickly with seafood prices up
nearly 20 percent this year
we're back in two minutes to discuss
this is quick
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
jennifer zabasaja and i'm tim stenoveck
in
new york well if you've been thinking
about everything that costs more at the
grocery store these days you
might be right earlier we were talking
about oil and gas
inflation and now it's time to talk a
little bit about food check this out
seafood prices up 18.7 percent on
average last month
donuts and bread were up eight percent
that's according to nielsen iq
in fact 50 of the 52 categories tracked
by nielsen are more expensive than a
year ago
with only butter and milk holding
essentially flat while everything around
them
skyrockets joining us now is bloomberg
intelligence commodities strategist mike
mcglone
mike why is this happening to our
grocery bills
i think part of that team is supply
bottlenecks related to covet but the key
thing to point out
for to look forward to is corn is one of
the best performing commodities this
year it's up 50
and it's the world's most significant
agricultural commodity as measured by
dollar cost of production
and guess what corn usually peaks around
may or june because the market's
pricing for a bit of a drought it
doesn't get it and then massive supply
comes on this year i expect to see the
biggest crop in the history of mankind
in north america most note of the corn
belt partly because we haven't had this
kind of incentive to produce
in a long time and technology has really
picked up so what i see is the markets
at the upper end of the range
more likely head back lower as we get to
the fall we see the crop come on
yeah mike that's what i was going to ask
you i mean is this like a short-term
spike or
will our grocery bills be more expensive
in the long term here well i think it's
a short-term spike from the wholesale
price now the
retail price is a little more different
obviously in defense and distribution
and everything
but i think that's getting becoming
we're getting past that with covid from
a wholesale price point standpoint
corn has basically been between a price
of three and eight since 2006. six was
important when we started the ethanol
mandate and guess what's happening we're
up the upper end of the range
i just talked to a good friend who's a
man manager of farmers
in the midwest and he expects fence post
to fence post planting massive supply
and unless we get a drought we're going
to see see next thing we'll see is signs
and pictures of corn piles we have just
too much of it in soybeans
okay so i i get it when it comes to to
corn and soybeans but but why something
like fish
why something like meat well there you
go
fish and meat are not actively trade of
futures so a little bit out of my league
but they trickle down how do you feed
meat corn corn is the number one
supplier
the key demand source for corn is feed
corn the thing is
look forward look 10 years from now
we're not going to be driving as much
vehicles we're not going to need the
ethanol and
there's alternatives to meat i mean in
bloomberg here we have
fake meat and that's early days it's
just like this when we first got our
cell phones they weren't so great but
give that 10 years
we're not going to need as much of this
and people keep saying the populations
are growing
it's not global population growth on an
incremental basis 10-year difference is
the lowest it's been in almost history
it's running around 10 percent
so mike you don't see any of this as
cause for concern at this point in time
i don't i do not i think a short-term
transitory and a key thing will be
by the time we're having this
conversation in august and september if
corn prices are where they are now then
i'll worry so the front price is around
seven
delivery for december is closer to six
and near five
six dollars a bushel i think we're going
to get closer to that if we get a big
crop it's going to drop below five so
this is a conversation for us to really
have for definitive reasons back
by every time we get to august right now
it's not even june yet
and the co and we're just starting with
emergence okay but there are real world
implications to this especially when
people are at the grocery store they
look at how much something costs and
they're saying wait a second i'm not
going to buy that
i'm going to buy something else how does
that play out in the economy and what
does it say
about where we are in the economy key
point i'm glad you make that tim it's
completely macro economic it reduces
spending
you're not going to buy the more
expensive food when gas prices
pumped in 2008 it reduced spending
people had to find places allocated just
reduces people's
paychecks this is not good mike this is
not good for the economy
consumer spending is what powers this
economy the consumer powers this economy
if we are not opening our wallets and
buying what we
what we were planning to buy that is bad
for economic growth and just imagine if
the stock market goes down what that
means so i don't think so the whole
thing trickles down this stock market
has to keep going up or people are not
going
to
feel wealthy and actually they're
feeling not wealthy right now
because the government checks are being
gone soon are leaving soon and
everything costs more
well we love to have you on the show
bloomberg intelligence commodity
strategist mike mcglone thank you so
much for joining us and breaking this
all down for us this morning
coming up not every doge finds its way
we're looking into the ups and downs of
dogecoin and other cryptos this weekend
after elon musk's odd spectacle on
snl we'll be back in two minutes to
discuss this is quick take charge
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists policy
makers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenovich and i'm jennifer zabasaja
in new york dogecoin investors had a
wild ride this weekend
after hitting a record on saturday ahead
and ahead of
elon musk's appearance on saturday night
live the digital currency began to fall
hours before the show began and
continued to drop as he delivered his
opening monologue though it did see a
little boost towards the end
during weekend update take a look it's
the future of currency
it's an unstoppable financial vehicle
that's going to take over the world
oh so it's a hustle yeah it's awesome
yes he did say that it's a roller
coaster ride that other digital tokens
like ether and binance coin are familiar
with and recent jumps are even starting
to
out join bitcoin so what does this all
mean
for the crypto movement joining us now
is bloomberg markets reporters katie
greifeld and bailey lipschultz thank you
both
for being here katie we're going to
start with you giving you the big
question of the day
did the doge father deliver this weekend
well it really depends on your
perspective in terms of sketch comedy i
thought he was pretty good but
if you were hoping on a dogecoin pop
coming out of this weekend you're
probably feeling a little bit
disappointed right now i mean
as you said in the open you did see
doe's rally
coming into saturday it was as high as
72 cents but
currently where we are on monday morning
it's about 50 cents so
really big fall from grace there and
i mean elon musk he did call it a hustle
that was a joke but it was already
falling
into that and i think the bigger story
here is that this was a sell the news
event you see this all the time in
traditional markets
where you see assets rally going into a
big
day such as a product announcement or
earnings release
and then kind of trail off after and you
are seeing that here where dogecoin is
dropping a little bit it did rally a bit
as musk was talking but
again it's a pretty big drop so far
bailey we learned yesterday that uh elon
musk said he would
start accepting or should this spacex
would start accepting
uh dogecoin for uh one product uh in
2022
the so-called cube seed it's a mini
satellite used for space research that
will embark on a moon voyage in 2022
uh it will be paid for entirely in
dogecoin
this is like seems to me among the the
only legitimate uses for for doge apart
from some that mark cuban
has talked about but it does seem to be
are people taking dogecoin seriously
more seriously than i'm taking it
i don't know if this is doing much i
think it's more interesting that elon is
planning into 2022 that doge will still
be relevant as we've seen
with meme stocks you know the life cycle
is pretty quick and if you're a retail
trader you're
kind of playing hot potato jumping from
one asset to another
i think it helps but at the end of the
day you have to think about it and say
you know what
elon musk is still the doge father he's
still the one driving the news and
trying to keep it relevant
so it kind of makes sense it's almost
like saying
someone who's bullish on corn futures
saying they're going to
accept corn futures as a payment in
2022. well
that kind of reiterates your your
bullishness so i still think it's
it seems very much like a joke uh some
of the
dogecoin experts that i talked to when i
say that jokingly
are still bullish on the opportunity but
it seems kind of a question of what the
next
real catalyst to katie's point could be
for another rally
um but as we've discussed over the last
few weeks nothing really about the
initial rally
was logical so it would not surprise me
to see doge move in either direction
over the next
six weeks and so katie on that point
what
what does this mean for other digital
coins out there right now
well it's interesting you actually are
seeing the doze rally even though it's
built on pretty much nothing it is
having ripple effects into the broader
crypto sphere
if you look at bitcoin's market share of
the total crypto
crypto universe which is currently
around 2.6 trillion
its share has dropped from 70 at the
start of the year
all the way to 43 so quite a steep drop
there
and that's because you're seeing a lot
of retail demand just for
other coins i mean in addition to
dogecoin you also have things like
ether you have binance coins so there's
this growing comfort
and this growing interest in investing
outside of bitcoin
which for so long was just really much
the
the only game in town when it came to
crypto and
if you are looking for a silver lining
though data track it's a research shop
it looked at historical trends and it
thinks should bitcoin's market share
drop below 40 you could see a rebound in
bitcoin
sort of as this buy-the-dip mentality
emerges so this is going to be something
to watch whether this
this altcoin rally if you want to call
it that continues or at a certain point
whether
people looking for a bargain go back
into bitcoin bailey i know you cover
uh meme stocks equities uh closely
i i'm wondering what the relationship is
between the way that people are talking
about doge
in the forums the way that they talked
about it over the weekend what we saw
from elon musk
if if that has any relationship to the
way that they
talked about and and bought into uh
companies like gamestop
i think there is a similarity um the
tougher part
is kind of the divide so people who have
adopted doge to katie's point there are
other companies or other coins to buy
into and we're seeing a lot of money
being pushed into that not necessarily
selling doge but other opportunities
that kind of are catching an interest
it's kind of like looking at
a dog when they see a squirrel they get
excited and they want to chase the next
squirrel
that's really what we're seeing with
some of these cryptocurrencies and it is
similar
to gamestop but we saw gamestop rally
take a dip and
a bit of a breather it hit above 480
twice
so there's still enough buying demand
it's just a question of
will doge be where people want to
continue to put money in
especially with the understanding that
the risk is realistically a hundred
percent
there's not really a sound fundamental
basis in doge as opposed to gamestop
where
you can say ryan cohen and they're
selling goods and they're still a
company
dogecoin could drop to zero
theoretically tomorrow and there's no
reason that it should go any other
direction so bailey then
i guess should we even be thinking about
whether this is peak doge or not i mean
is it just going to continue to change
every day
i think it is it's something we've seen
in the past when elon musk was announced
that he was going to be headlining or
guest hosting snl we saw that the crypto
run
drop and we've seen a number of 50 ish
dips and then as katie said people buy
those dips we don't really know again
it's
it's tough to try to talk about or look
into the future of something that
up to this point hasn't made much sense
uh so we could have been peak dosh we
could see
people buying into ether or other
kryptos or kind of just go back about
their their days and go
live life and enjoy going to bars and
concerts and restaurants
and neither would be surprising but as
long as you have a movement
uh it really will be tough to die and
elon obviously is doing everything in
his power
to keep doge relevant and to keep doge
in the headlines hey
katie to bailey's point about ether
and people buying into ether let's talk
a little bit about the idea of froth
which some analysts
have brought up with broth in the in the
crypto market for example jp morgan
says it's retail trader demand for uh
other coins
is potentially uh whittling away bitcoin
market share uh potentially froth
that is is reminiscent of what happened
in 2017 where we saw a big sell-off
in bitcoin uh take me through
similarities to what analysts are saying
now
uh versus what happened back then and
and what it means for the legitimacy of
crypto
well froth feels like the favorite word
on wall street right now and it's
definitely been thrown around a lot when
it comes to cryptocurrencies
and it goes back again to that market
share argument that you're seeing
bitcoin's market share just
whittled away by all of this interest in
altcoins
some of them serious such as ether some
of them you know
a joke such as dogecoin but i really
want to dial in on ether because i think
this is really interesting because
in the realm of serious cryptocurrencies
ether definitely falls into that
bucket because it's the currency the
cryptocurrency used within the ethereum
blockchain which is
powering things such as non-fungible
tokens which are very hot right now
and jp morgan's warning that this feels
like 2017
in terms of just how much froth there is
in the crypto market right now
they also applied that to ether
specifically saying that
even though the ethereum blockchain
network it has a lot of promise
the ether rally that we're seeing it hit
4 000
today even though we were talking about
3 000 last week
the the rally there it's starting to
outpace the actual activity that you're
seeing on the ethereum network so
they actually estimate that ether's fair
value is probably closer to
1 000 and again we're at 4 000 so
that's a pretty big disconnect so
whether this froth
boils over and we see this bubble pop if
you want to call it that
remains to be seen but you i think that
they're
trying to make the point that you would
probably see it in this this altcoin
sphere that
is really just on fire right now well
explain explain exactly what analysts
mean when they say froth the term that
we heard from
fed chair jay powell just a few weeks
ago when he he gave his press conference
but essentially what they're saying is
hey
there are signs that things are a little
overvalued exactly that that just
there's a lot of exuberance and
excitement in the market right now
not just in crypto you could easily
apply that argument to the stock market
as well
and that things have gotten a little bit
ahead of themselves and
again in ether's case there's a lot of
promise in the ethereum blockchain
they're not discounting that
but just the magnitude of this rally and
the pace of these gains
it's starting to get a little bit ahead
of itself and you could see that asset
correct
hey bailey what are you looking at next
i mean what should we be paying
attention to now that snl has passed us
i mean
uh elon musk is still talking about
dogecoin but um
what are you going to be paying
attention to i'm still paying attention
to
some of the over-the-counter traded
stocks some of these smaller more
speculative
uh meme stocks a lot of retail traders
are still have the
get rich buy lotto tickets uh mentality
when they're making these investments
obviously they are putting money into
you know your big blue chip
uh tech companies you're they're putting
money into amazon's the microsoft's of
the world
but there still is a mentality that if i
can turn a thousand dollars into thirty
thousand dollars and buy a car
i'm gonna take that risk and so a lot of
people are still looking at
um those opportunities be it gamestop
still is a bit overrun but looking at
you know naked brands or um express are
still companies that
are thinly traded have the opportunity
to see big booms and busts if they can
just
get the right chat room to pick up the
right chatter and then see everyone else
jump into it so it's a lot of trying to
play ahead of the curve or to use a
hockey term stick skate to where the
puck's going to go
and try to beat the crowd and that's
something we saw initially with doge um
just a couple months ago
bloomberg katie greifeld and bailey lip
schultz love talking crypto thank you
for
joining us on quick take this morning
great to see both of you
well coming up why the shutdown of
another nuclear power plant in new york
could be a setback for u.s emissions
goals we're back in two minutes to
explain
this is quick take charge
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenovich and i'm jennifer zappasaja
in new york in
new york's indian in new york indian
point's last nuclear reactor went dark
in april
it's the 12th nuclear reactor to close
since 2013
and will be replaced by fossil fuels for
the short term that
may hurt the us's ambitions in green
energy production so quick takes ryan
cavatero visited the plant
a week before it went dark take a listen
nuclear is in a crisis mode nuclear
power
provides the greatest amount of carbon
free generation that the u.s has today
35 miles north of manhattan two nuclear
reactors provided around 25 percent of
the electricity for the big apple
you do the math you understand why
indian points closure
is absolutely the only smart move but
losing a nuclear reactor
hurts the us's goals of a carbon-free
future
this is the decade we must make
decisions that will avoid the worst
consequences of the climate crisis
this is the story of indian point energy
center and how the closed power plant
can impede
zero emissions goals and be a specter of
a vanishing atomic future
well it used to be that indian point was
an amusement park
which is kind of amazing to me families
took boats up the hudson river to
buchanan new york to ride the roller
coasters
there's 300 miles of the hudson river
it's been a conduit for commerce haven
for recreation
nuclear reactors require a lot of water
to keep them cool they must have looked
at that property and thought oh this is
a great place
for a nuclear plant
con edison acquired the land in 1954.
the company finished construction of the
unit 1 nuclear reactor
in 1964. two more reactors followed
unit 2 went online in 1974 and unit 3 in
1976
and then in 2000 entergy purchased unit
3 from the state
and unit 2 from con ed when both of
those reactors were operating he
supplied about 25 percent of the
electricity to
new york city it's a very valuable piece
of power
before we continue about indian point
what is nuclear power
fission nuclear power is splitting of
heavy elements like uranium
into smaller particles and in the
process of doing that releasing a
tremendous amount of energy
that energy in the form of heat is used
to heat water
that is then turned into steam and that
steam goes ahead and spins the turbine
and generates electricity nuclear is
complex technology obviously
this is michael schellenberger he's an
author and he's advocated for nuclear
power
in front of congress but the plants
themselves they're just power plants
there's
steam generators that spin turbines that
make electricity
over the years attitudes started to
shift towards indian point
there's two reasons the combinations a
lot of political opposition
from environmental groups to go ahead
and close the nuclear power plant
because they were scared
especially in the wake of fukushima that
a similar accident could happen
over here river keeper has been watching
the
indian point power plant for decades
we've observed
that as the plant ages it becomes more
of a safety risk beyond its failure to
comply with the clean water act
the indian point plant consumes more
water every day
than the city of new york and after 9 11
we realize that as this plant ages it
becomes more and more of a risk
to the 20 million people who live within
50 miles
entergy disputes those claims pointing
to large investments in plant safety
and reliability there are people on all
sides of this
issue there were people that never
wanted the plant here
and other people recognized the value to
the economy
then in 2017 amid contract discussions
new york governor andrew cuomo and
entergy made a decision
i've personally been trying to close it
down for 15 years
finally this year i'm proud to announce
that we have an agreement
indian point will close in four years 14
years
ahead of schedule
in addition to environmental concerns
the economics in an unregulated power
market
no longer made sense in january 2017
entergy announced that it was shutting
down indian point unit 2 by
2020 unit 3 by 2021. the primary
decision was related to
a drop in wholesale power prices i mean
the big story in energy of course over
the last decade and a half
is the fracking revolution which made
natural gas really cheap in the united
states and that's put price pressure
on both coal plants and nuclear plants
in some places
the decommissioning process will take
around 15 years
new yorkers will be safer from the risk
of a disaster at the plant
but what will replace the lost energy
between 2017 and 2021
when they were planning on
decommissioning the reactors almost two
gigawatts
of fossil fired power came online within
50 miles of
indian point so unfortunately we are
replacing
in the immediate future the electricity
generated by indian point
not by renewables but by fossil fuels in
the form of those
natural gas power plants an indian point
i think stands
as a dramatic warning that carbon
emissions will go up
we have very very ambitious goals
present administration has also said
that it wants to have a carbon-free
electrical power system
by 2035. it's not possible to radically
reduce
your carbon emissions or your use of
fossil fuels without nuclear power the
nuclear right now provides a little bit
under 20
of our electricity i think the biden
climate legislation gives so much
subsidies to solar and wind that it
could end up accelerating the closure of
nuclear plants
and must have a counterproductive impact
in terms of emissions
you know when the sun sets is when
people come home from work and start to
use all their power so there's no
innovation to solar panels that can make
them
work better at night and wind similarly
is not reliable
especially if you think that weather is
becoming more extreme
nuclear power plants they're very very
dense source electricity that generates
a lot of electricity all the time the
power sources of the future will be a
combination of renewables
and nuclear power if we are really
serious about
reaching net zero in the time frames
that the current administration has gone
ahead and identified
indian point unit 3 is the 12th reactor
to close since the beginning of 2013.
right now there are 55 sites and 93
reactors in operation
reactors in michigan and california are
expected to close in the next few years
and there are two advanced reactor sites
under construction in georgia that have
exceeded
original budgets
i mean the most important thing for the
united states to do right now is to
keep our nuclear power plants operating
and build more reactors
similar to the ones that are already in
construction in georgia
nuclear is both scary and beneficial
for the same reason i think a lot of
people have viewed the ability to do
that as a curse
or that we'll be in trouble with the
gods but i think that increasingly
people understand it as a blessing
nuclear power plants cannot go off like
a weapon and they don't depend on
weapons or vice versa
but it's sort of the anxieties from one
have displaced onto the other and that's
why you get people that believe things
that just aren't true
so how does nuclear power fit into our
energy future
there's a lot of policy mechanisms that
policy makers at the state or the
federal level can use
but i think really what matters is being
able to explain to people why nuclear is
an important technology
that's here to stay it's not something
that we could or should try to get rid
of and said we need to make the most of
it
[Music]
and thanks to quick takes ryan cavatero
for that really great reporting
coming up does a 40 000 one-time bonus
sound good to you i think it would
well some companies are doubling their
bonuses to try to keep
employees from jumping ship we'll
explain in two minutes with the details
this is quick take charge
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport
industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenovic and i'm jennifer zabasaja
in new york so let's look at some
developing stories we are tracking this
morning
president biden is preparing for his
first face-to-face meeting with
republican leaders mitch mcconnell
and kevin mccarthy wednesday's meeting
comes as republicans
are ramping up their opposition to the
president's four trillion dollar
economic plan
there's not much expectation for a
breakthrough at the meeting
there's not much there's not much
expectation for a breakthrough at the
meeting
last week mcconnell said he is a hundred
percent focused
on blocking biden's agenda
and you can learn more about these
stories and stay up to date with the
day's news at bloomberg.com well that's
going to do it for quick take this hour
but there's much more quick date coming
up in just a minute i'm tim stenovich
i'm jennifer zabasage to check out these
stories at bloomberg.com
or a quick take on social media
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
good afternoon and welcome to bloomberg
quick take where we bring today's top
news and break down how it intersects
with the world of business
coming up on this afternoon show we're
bringing you the latest from the fallout
of that major cyber attack on the
biggest u.s fuel pipeline as it
continues
the white house now has an interagency
task force moving quickly to stop the
hackers
as the shutdown drags into its third day
meantime
new details emerging about the main
suspect in the attack the ransomware
group known
as darkseid then facebook's mark
zuckerberg is being pressured to abandon
plans to create a version of instagram
for children
under 13. we'll break down what 44
attorneys general said to the silicon
valley giant
including the claim that facebook has
historically failed to protect the
welfare
of children on its platforms and the
book on bezos i'm going to speak with
the author of the brand new book out
tomorrow amazon
unbound jeff bezos and the invention of
a global empire
what he learned about amazon's
billionaire founder and as the book
calls it
the most important business story of our
time
good afternoon everyone it's monday may
10th i'm tim stenoveck in new york and
this
is take a break let's do this
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and thanks so
much for joining us well we begin with
the us's biggest pipeline it remains
shuttered for a third day following a
major
hack attack as a result drivers along
the east coast may soon see higher
prices at the pump and the white house
has put together
an interagency task force to address the
colonial pipeline cyber attack
and as the investigation continues our
next guest says the key to confronting
these cyber attacks is for companies
and the government to be transparent
joining us now to discuss is
bloomberg opinion senior columnist tim
o'brien and bloomberg cyber security
reporter elisa sabanes
who's been tracking the white house's
response to the attack
a big thank you to both of you for
joining us elisa i want to start with
you because you have a brand new
uh peace out in the fbi also just
moments ago releasing a statement that
says quote
the fbi confirms that the dark side
ransomware is responsible for the
compromise of the
colonial pipeline networks we continue
to work with the company and our
government partners on
the investigation elisa what is darkseid
and and what do we know about this group
darkside is a really interesting
ransomware group that popped up
according to cybersecurity researchers
this summer
i spoke to a number of researchers in
the course of my reporting
that have dealt with other attacks
having to do with darkseid
they say that darkseid typically demands
ransoms
in millions of dollars range when they
take people's data
hostage uh in addition some
people have suggested that there are
links between the group
and russia although this is unconfirmed
so for example there are certain email
addresses that are affiliated